quand palace hotel c'est quoi d'abord
palace hotel c'est un truc glauque comme
voix et jean vient en tête c'est dans
une histoire sur pouvoir c
c'est un tournant politique totalitaire
on ne sait pas à signer de droite de
gauche ou son chou
se réfugier dans un palace sous terre un
bunker qui est fait pour le sécuriser
pour nous protéger en cas de coup dur
nous coup dur arrive dès le début du
film on ne sait pas ce que c'est mon
plus enfin il faut combler beaucoup de
chance et beaucoup d'ellipses parce que
je voulais pas tout le montrer et c'est
visiblement un guerre civile
et
et un des personnages importants de
chine personnages étranges au crâne rasé
descendre c'est dans un endroit étrange
par un ascenseur étrange
et à
va retourner l'instant toute une série
de
personnalité aller carole bouquet - les
channel mieux aller oui un bien pour
l'image qu'à ses volontés la casse et de
lapins de carlo des noirs
qu'est ce qu'on dit qu'au malawi derrick
rose mary cros ya trintignant c'est lui
qui a rasé
c'est lui qui a craint passé alors il
avait dit qu'il ferait plus de cinéma
trintignant comment ça se fait qu'il a
craqué il a le scénario et je trouve
étrange jamais trouvé des trucs comme ça
oui et puis et puis on s'est rencontré
ça a bien marché en tournage a commencé
à boulogne non non je suis pas tombé à
billancourt au départ on devait tourner
bien court départ insultes et de musc
oui et puis après ça s'est terminé à
belgrade pays l'ont tué
est né là-bas en 51 1 sais tu as trouvé
changé le pays ah bon enfin la ville n'a
pas changé ouais c'est détendu voilà le
coeur de la ville n'a pratiquement pas
changé les gens les gens j'ai beaucoup
je ne sais pas comment ils font pour
pour vivre dans des conditions
difficiles économique du pays bas ils
ont une espèce de force nos pêches
croyable enfin bon ils sortent ils vont
dans les restaurants et ils font trois
ou quatre boules aux parallèles ou leur
fassent étonnant c'est l'italie des
années 50 quoi c'est peut-être ça que ça
parce que c'est ce qui est drôle c'est
que ce soit au tournage la construction
du décor on voyait arriver d équipe
inédite tous les jouets qui dans la
journée c'est un boulot et la nuit
faisait charpentier ou même un trou mais
son état c'est non mais toi tu as vécu
là bas jusqu'à l'âge de 10 ans non
encore tu étais petit avait le foulard
tu défilé au pas tu étais pionniers nom
était pionnière bien elle rouge le petit
foulard rouge et puis bah oui mais ça
c'est des bons souvenirs
c'est des bons souvenirs ça moi c'était
pas l'armée comme moi mais c'était une
espèce de l'embrigadement léger qui
préparaient des choses plus graves
négoce navy n'a pas souvent et
heureusement
alors ton père tu travailles dans la
couture il est venu travailler en france
et un jour d'avouer à ta maîtresse à
l'école que ton père voulait aller
habiter en france et on est resté quand
même pas entre saint-louis à 10 ans et
il tombe enfin je sais pas comment ça
s'est passé mais il vous en donner le
visa condition que vous leur donniez
l'appartement
je peux bons procédés savait des choses
tu as été très influencé par l'est quand
même par ses dix ans passés là bas quand
tu dis je des figures jeu qu'on series
la réalité c'est quand même cette vision
de la yougoslavie d'après guerre que tu
te transcrit sans arrêt non un peu oui
mais en même temps c'est pas c'est pas
si sordide que kebede semaine je sais
pas quand tu parles de tramway c'est pas
sordide mais les murs où il restait les
les impacts de balle tout ça c'est quand
même et c'est toujours là c'est toujours
là les impacts de balles sur les
bâtiments officiels ils sont tous côtés
le temps qu'on sent les rides et
nostalgie c'est quand même ça n'arrive
pas à ce combat il faut de l'argent pour
qu'on essaie ça le problème
faut du fric c'est comme un if this way
c'est une chance inouïe un truc avec la
vois pas ce que je pourrais me faire
comprendre de fond j'en ai un stand à la
fête on prendra tout à l'heure quand tu
as une chance inouïe parce que quand tu
es arrivé en france ben tahar passé dix
ans à faire évidemment des études puis
un jour il ya eu un concours organisé
par pilote
tu as gagné qui prouve que tu étais pas
mauvais déjà épique au 6bisarts engagé
par un k way d'abord anthony si rossi
avant on était tous dans les 10e et 11e
j avais tennis swiss au total quoi sauf
toi moi je suis nulle produisit ouais
c'est vrai quand même sa lente et une
carrière de rêve non je peux recommencer
c'est allé très
très progressivement moi je crois tiens
c'est que ce que j'ai envie de faire je
vais je vais au bout quand il faut une
petite part d'inconscience pour faire un
film quoi là je suis très content parce
que je suis beau et que c'est bien quand
on s'adresse t copier je crois que suis
dur à copier je crois que c'est dur
recopier parce que ceux qui copient a
peur un moment de ce qu'il confie je
crois je travaille vite
ouais séries tu t'écoutes quoi parles-tu
travail j'écoute de la musique alors
j'écoute tout ce moment un jour
dgo
je suis capable d'écouter même la
variété est ce qui m'étonne beaucoup de
même genre quoi par exemple la bonne
donc après elle par exemple être non
j'écoute ou j'écoute du classique que
j'écoute la bande fm
ou alors j'ai déjà coûté truc que je
découvre de temps en temps un groupe
russe centre arrière privative est assez
génial the way
j'ai acheté sur la poche et un homme qui
soit mais après cet incident a envie de
retourner travailler à l'aise comme ça
elle est là tant que j'aurai besoin
cette approche et non non c'est
simplement pour des raisons financières
mais ce qu'annonce et aussi pour des
raisons de nous des corps quand même
l'extérieur de belgrade j'aurais pas
trouvé en france qu'en extérieur et tout
ça et moi j'aime mardi à tournai
effectivement et à berlin et à trac
parce que c'est des villes où il a fait
un truc sur le mur de berlin hier un
portfolio lac était très très pauvre ah
oui mais ça c'est ça l'europe comme ces
normes sont un succès le coeur de
l'europe
et là il ya encore des décors qui sont
bien parce que sinon les villes
occidentales moi j'adore ça mais elles
seront sans doute maintenant un peu
grande banlieue et si tu es resté une
définition de toile un dictionnaire ce
serait quoi que tu aimerais équivalent
de points on va les guillemets je pense
non mais c'est sûr qu'il faut les
laisser aux à ceux qui écrivent ainsi on
ne regarde que celuici par d'illustrés
adoré du 20e siècle par exemple j'ai
entendu dire ça j'ai entendu que j'étais
le pape de la bd j'entendais d'état
reconnaît oui oui je trouve ça con way
[Musique]
les corrections de ne rien rater de
finale andy tube abonnez vous il m'était
impossible eux